[Music]
I need to focus on mix baccarat and I
need three person fifties
no problem my nails like the new girl on
the block and I'm just hoping that she
can cope with such a demand because
she's the least experienced leave often
baby as a starter she's serving coconut
pities potato and chickpea chat and
spicy vegetable pakoras me leave dad run
make the tad forces
this will be the hardest service of
their lives
now I need now she may be inexperienced
but my nails got to drive this kitchen
like never before
your boss on Bakura clean boss on Betty
dear my number four all right simple
this many ways this assertive in terms
of car yeah just Metro is 150 percent
mummy Billy one weekend dad when I walk
but however hard me now pushes a team
they're barely able to keep up and this
is just the first course I told you what
you I got it
just listen what I'm saying
you can tell it's been put together not
very very fresh I thought salads
excellent it's nicely spiced not too
hard but just right every plate fee was
incredible tu-204
all of them say fantastic food really
really happy okay
halfway there keep it going guys yes big
portion of my courses now you want me to
make a boy but the mains will be even
harder every deep-fried puri and dosa
pan cake needs to be precisely timed
only one hour left so you know I'm
getting funny
what does that bother sir
Prasad small kitchen is going
hell-for-leather but these dishes just
aren't leaving fast enough well yeah how
long do they normally wait between
courses roughly 10 minutes yet so the
kitchen the size the gallery cook up
such a space generally to get one grill
got three large head without waking
rancor teacher I need now I said that
the pressures really on
and some diners have been waiting for an
hour just to let you know guys that this
afternoon obviously we have all 30
guests in at once there may be a little
bit of a wait for your mains I hope you
can be patient with this said be patient
that she's fine as I understand also
just having a good time
explain to them the kind about the fact
that you'll be a little while but
obviously me there is a deadline on how
much time we've got to serve I said
white people are to every blasted
modality glasses oh no hurry up now
there's great synergy there between the
dining room and the kitchen and they're
working pretty well together they're
supporting each other through every
plate Digby's come on hurry up take it
hurry up now last four main courses yes
yes the main courses have been badly
delayed but Bobby's charm of the dining
room has kept the customers on side and
averted a crisis lifting electric things
interesting
it's nice turbines I'm really enjoying
it it's absolute delicious
Wow this rice hotter in the center it's
lovely
it's heaven on the plate even the most
ardent carnivores have been converted
amazing presentation and then the test
itself was lived up toilet look at some
time gives even man and it looked you
know I think I think we'll try and come
here again service is over see ya
buh-bye okay and it's time for the
Prasad team to hear my verdict okay um
let's cut to the chase
the the problem I have having witnessed
the service is that you've you've now
just completely and I mean really
completely blown open this whole
competition because it Rose it you raise
the bar